this is a production of Cornell
University
yeah I will talk about tree selection
and hopefully I will end this
presentation within the time otherwise
we see what's will do I will start to
try to explain what I mean with
improving or herbal resilience when it
comes to tree selection because today
the urban habitat or the last decades
also the urban green infrastructure have
been identified as a very important
element in order to create the
resilience to both current happenings
but also future happenings like climate
change but also new functions we're
given more and more people in urban
areas and more pressure to urban areas
and the green infrastructure have been
identified as one of the most important
elements in order to meet these changes
and new demands for urban environments
and when you look at the green
infrastructure goes from everything from
there cut lawn to shrubbery to pocket
woodlands street trees green roof green
walls even the pots on a balcony all
this together is recognized as a green
infrastructure but when you look at the
plans which individual plans
implementation that they have they're
the biggest impact trees is outstanding
when it comes to delivering different
kind of services and function and we
talked about this ecosystem services the
trees can be delivering from urban
environments in order to create
resilience and so on and this is just a
compilation by Johanna in her thesis and
I just stole it is easier just steal
stuff that's how we do they just stole
it but it shows really good when what
trees and urban the green infrastructure
and the most things did you hear about
is this regulating ecosystem serves like
stormwater management micro climate
mitigation pollution relief and so on
but there are also others functional a
cultural provision supporting ecosystem
services as well where trees can and
have the capacity to deliver a great
share all this together because when we
come to urban environments today
spaces where it's allowed for a
tree-planting or plantation it get fewer
and fewer so the few places where you're
allowed to plant trees this plantation
is not only to be a good looking space
to create a local indentity for the
place it's equally important to serve
many kind of function so that's why tree
selection is really really crucial when
it comes to create a resilient in urban
environment however and also this that
their capacity for the trees to deliver
a function increase by space and
condition so well growing trees large
trees of course deliver and all have the
higher capacity to live with this
function so therefore the thing we plant
here have to reach to this in order to
create this resilience and so on so what
we are doing the plant selection is
really really important and that
includes of course site preparation but
good in plant environment but also the
plant selection that's why we focus on
this speaks in a way and this is
actually how it looks many times this is
actually a plant this is an a parking
space in a southern Sweden this is it
looks worse than it is actually this is
a space where water can go through and
it's a structural soil here so the main
idea here was that this plantation
should mitigate the urban heat island
effect by shading the space but also
shading the cars so the dogs and people
in the cars and I directly it takes some
time but also the space is part of their
local stormwater management in order to
mitigate that as well so it's good but
what the problem is here is completely
wrong plant materials are selecting the
selecting a sycamore maple a maple tree
that needs most condition more or less
or throughout the season and even if
this is a good space the situation will
not give that so the plants were
actually completely wrong here so you
could completely fail and it cost a lot
of money we doing that and this is not a
situation in southern Sweden you can see
the both air and ether
New York City all over the world where
plant selection is completely wrong for
sites and we have to because it cost a
lot of money to replace this and also
producing trees are going to die and so
on so just stupid so we have to increase
our knowledge about the plants election
so that's one side of the cone when a
coin when it comes to plant selection
the other ones is this there is the lack
of diversity within urban areas this is
a study we did a couple of years ago in
Scandinavia when we evaluate their urban
tree population in Denmark Finland
Norway and Sweden and this is the street
environment in Helsinki you know this
capital Finland or slow capital of
Norway you can see it's just few species
to stand for the dominance and if a
disease hits one of these Oslo risk to
lose most forty four point three percent
of the street tree in just over a year
maybe but then you lose the resilience
for that and it takes many many years in
order to build that up again and this is
not a Scandinavian problem only this is
an international problem a problem this
is from a study we are working on will
try to evaluate the tree diversity in
urban areas around the world in the
northern hemisphere and this is treating
violence as well you see Pittsburgh four
species stand for more than half of the
population Beijing China three species
Camden which is a borough in central
London UK four species Spain three
species down four so this is a a
situation we have around the world there
is a lack of diversity and you can't say
lack of diversity and resilient the same
centers it's not possible it's not it's
not going so what we're standing in
front of the - my main challenge we
stand in front of its first increased
knowledge about untraditional or rare
tree species in order to introduce a
wider diversity of urban trees but
secondly start to understand or try to
develop knowledge about their capacity
this new one traditional plant materials
in order to grow on relay
challenging growing condition but also
their capacity to deliver in different
kind of ecosystem services so these are
the two challenge we stand in front of a
day and the work we are doing they have
done for many years but we're doing here
and Cannell and we probably going to
continue forever and ever anyway so this
is when I this is just an introduction
were like to talk about so developing
site related knowledge this is what Nina
said learning from nature because in
nature trees on plants generally have
developed different kind of trades and
strategies or even personalities in
order to compete for resources in order
to compete for or tolerate different
kind of climates and growing condition
so by developing knowledge about which
kind of traits species have is easy to
find their use potential also in urban
environments so this is not rocket
science pretty common sense because in
nature there is plants like this plants
that can take more or less everything
they have a lot of different kind of
super power plants that can take a punch
or two and still be standing I have a
quote area I really like this is Mike
Tyson everybody has a plan until they
get punched in the face and this is
really good because this is what it's
all about some have a plan how to take
this punch and still be good looking
still be standing still be performing
well but their plants they don't have
any sorry exactly and then they are
plants which are stupid or maybe not
that clever that have developed less
different I can take many punches even
if this person probably deserve many
punches in the face anyway when it comes
to plant selection it's important to
start to know how well they can take or
which kind of superpowers or personality
plants have which kind of strategy to
trace to have but also how well
developed these different traits are
and in urban environment there is a lot
of stress factors that affect the trees
and one of the main stress factors that
trees is facing today will probably face
even more in the future climate is lack
of water so water stress is the main
Kandra streets in urban environments
because the urban environments are more
warmer climate with more effective
everest evapotranspiration but also you
have a very effective water runoff for
all these hard surfaces but also the
space for many trees especially below
ground is limited because of space of
pipes and other things in this
multifunctional place that's urban
environments represent today so what
we're focusing is drought stress for
trees and see what kind of superpowers
they have in order to deal with water
and this is some an compilation by our
colleagues han dry runs from my school
college that did this for a couple years
back when he tried to put together how
trees dealing with water stress and you
can see that you can divide them into
groups avoiding water stress and their
second is just take the water stress and
tolerated and I will start with
avoidance the tree hug trees can avoid
water stress and then you can have two
sub categories like maximal nicely water
this is a hard word for me awkward
situation is that good can you say it
there you go
I can't say
and that's that of course that's the
main thing is to invest in a root system
that can support the tree with water
that's the main avoiding strategy that
most of the plants do some are better
some are weaker but then we have this
one reduce water use or weed reduce
water loss but for example stoma stomata
closure reduce leaf and stem growth
they're investing in prevention of
leaves they Kakuta cooler but also this
one which is less attractive so to say
just throwing the leaves this is a
picture from closer of summer house in
the southern Sweden in a place we have a
thin sole layer we can rock sand just
half a metre soil after a couple of
weeks really warm and dry weather the
root system can't support the tree with
water anymore and some trees don't have
any second plan of Plan B - just just
rely on tree roots when the tree roots
fail I have no idea how to deal with the
situation so they go into panic and you
can see what's happening just throwing
the leaves in order to reduce the water
loss it's a very effective way you can
see it are many species this is the
birches bachelor pendula in Sweden but
you can also see it like this this is
from the plantation here at Cornell even
if you have a structured soil here which
is better than normal it's better than
it looked like these trees this is from
the august 4 years ago when they're
panicking they just have no idea what to
do the roots say to the root calls the
tree crown we have we don't have any
water down here so they go into panic
and don't want to lose something and
throw the leaves you can compare to the
trees here plant at the same time and
they have more or less an unlimited
rooting space and they still green and
doing well so this is an example of
avoidance strategy avoiding when it
comes to rules but there's other example
I'm avoiding strategies for example this
I think I show you this last year gonna
have to speak this is a silver lime see
the linden all these American names of
tree I'm very sorry about that Tila
tomentosa this is a picture from of
davia
and Moldavia but they they also invest
in a root system of course in order to
avoid but they'll also invest in other
tools for example possession leaves and
they invest in a special profession or
higher type which is this star hair
which is like small micro umbrellas
which covering there can you say
undecidedly for it's okay thank you
decide sorry about it on this side of
the leaf which reduce the loss of water
so that that's another avoidance
strategies the silver linden use and the
silver have another level of avoidance
strategy this is an interesting force
just on the border between Romania a
Republic of them of Moldavia you have to
bring your passport when you go into
this forest because you never know which
country gonna end in I've done that
mistake a couple times here you can say
the silver Linden in the oak forest and
this is a way of war warm and dry day
you can see also in the plantation here
that a warm day the silver Linden is
more silver compared to a moist and cool
day because in a warm day they turn the
leaf upside to the sky and by doing
their that their day to reflect away
some of the sunlight which makes the
leaves that's in heat up in the same
amount that's normal and if the leaf
doesn't warm up that much they don't
have to use a lot of water to cool down
the leaf there's a very clever way to in
a warm day reduce water loss by
reflecting away the sunlight and doesn't
get that up heated so to say so that's
right and that's one example of avoiding
strategies trees have in order so by
that's what part of the research we do
and try to identify all these types of
strategies avoidance strategies have and
also try to understand how good they are
root system course is good when when the
root system or in the soil dries up what
kind of other plants do you have in
order to step up and take the drought so
to say
but the thing is the same picture again
same situation very dry but there are
trees that have the same lack of water
in the soil the root system failed to
support the tree but the tree doing well
anyway so this is our interesting
strategy we are looking at the we have
been looking a little bit extra to this
tolerance that's taking the punch so the
second still be standing well and
looking good to take the drought in in
order to avoid it - so to say because
when it comes to a tolerance of water to
air water our limited water availability
there are several different kind of
strategy trees have developed osmotic
adjustment for example elastic
adjustment but also love low turgor loss
point which have been a special interest
for us because that's if you have a very
low turgor loss point you have the
potential to just shut up just to stand
there take the punches and wait out the
drought and then the weather rain
weather comes it just goes on business
as usual so that's the interesting to
see how much you can shut up and how
long you can do it so that's why three
three years ago we started our project
together which is a collaboration
between the Swedish agriculture
University Cornell with Nina but also
with MySQL College in UK with dr. Andrew
Ryan's and we called the project shut
the hell up or die which actually what
it's all about to try to see how much a
tree can or why they can standing there
and just shut the hell up but also see
how long you can take it how long how
many punches you can take because that's
important to see in situation where you
need to have trees that can standing and
taking the punch of the punish and still
looking good and deliver different solo
target loss points we thought that was
interesting to look at and turgor loss
point can be used as a universal measure
of physiological drought tolerance that
is quantified and measurable and this is
very attractive for me rank species in
terms of there
illogical drought tolerance because
today when you rev your literature is
done
it's tolerant for drought yeah but how
much job that's the problem we can't say
this is better than other ones and
that's very interactive that if it's
possible to rank species actually give a
number to actually say this is drought
solid this much and this is actually
this much then it's easier to pinpoint
which species that can be used on that
site because in that site you have to
take the drought this much and so on but
the problem before is that taking to
measuring the turgor loss point it's a
very complicated time sorry time
consuming thank you can you read minds a
time-consuming work which means that
maybe for a year you work with four or
five species then you can take the
turgor loss point for them and that's it
but when it comes to diversity we have
to look at a large share of species to
in order to see the potential or which
one can be introduced or to four
nurseries or landscape architects a tree
planners and so on the last three years
of four years ago a group in in China
together where the people in California
come up with that there is a close
relationship between osmotic adjustment
and turgor loss point and that makes it
possible in a much easier way to develop
or to take care out the turgor loss
point we can use another methodology but
also it's possible with new techniques
to use it more easy that makes it
possible to take targeted to create
turgor loss point in a much easy way and
faster way so last year we spent on more
or less a whole year to just adjusting
this pathology testing back and forward
because then the work that had been done
before have been developed for
subtropical tropical and Mediterranean
plant species and we are not there we
are working in temperate zone so that's
why we're testing back and forward so
the result last year have been actually
published or accepted for publication so
it's gonna be published any time here
and we was looking at maples 27
different species and genotype of maples
we tested last year when it comes to
turgor loss points and this is what I
thought it was interesting to actually
do some kind of ranking but also you can
see because the more negative pressure
you can take the longer you can shut up
longer you can take the drought after
the root system all this avoidance
strategies fail the then you can take a
longer drought before because turgor
loss point if I if I should explain it
is that when the root system fail to
deliver water you go into a wilting
position so the cell structure leaves
just shrinking and they can string drink
to a special level and then there just
implodes and then the cell structure
just gone the investment the trees have
done for that leaf everything is gone
they can't produce any food or any
photosynthesis anymore but this level
before the cell structure just implode
and destroyed different between
different species so some species can
take their three or four days while
drought and then the cell structure just
goes out but some they have a very
strong cell walls and so on so they can
take a long cells very what's a very low
negative pressure without get damaged so
this is what it is so these species down
here with a long I can take their cell
structure can take a long drought and a
very high negative pressure and by doing
that they can take the drought and still
have an active for the synthesis and
tear and still can capture resources and
invest in roots and the shots and and
things for next year and that's a very
positive thing but they speed it up in
the top there you can take it very short
and then the leaf structure destroyed is
that
understand or pretty clear okay they're
interesting here that there is a
difference between the season you can
see in the spring some of the species
that are very very strong in the summer
are weak you know in their spring that's
interesting when it comes to climate
change when we get have droughts in
different parts of the season that would
even thought before that would go
through and show it so what it means
more practically is that the trees or
the species or the genotypes that
belongs to their group up there which
have a very low negative pressure on the
cell structure these are the species
that rely very much on a root system or
voiding strategies so they should never
ever be planted outside very generous
parking Minds whether they're unlimited
resources for the roots but also have a
good water holding capacity in a soil
but when you look at the trees where
they grow naturally it makes sense
because a suspect caught them which was
the weakest one in this test this is the
place whether you can find it along
streams and some understory species in
moist Woodlands and that's the case also
for a certain Suvarna comb I have no
idea what these species are calls in
English I just stick to their there's
scientific names this is from a tree man
state park outside Ithaca but also a
certain quarter more mono whatever you
want to call it this is from the
tingling mountain in China what I did is
my PhD work a lot of field work but here
you can see it as an understory tree
inside a protected moist forest
environment so it makes sense the trees
to have a low drug loss point they grow
naturally in sides but it's a good
guidance also for tree plant is
Landscape Architect REITs don't have the
equipment to grow in street environments
where you have periods with really
severe droughts they should always be
your garden or poetry that's it
but don't know how the other group here
these are the guys that can take
droughts for a longer time they can pay
planted a more challenging growing
condition like this in a courtyard where
deep rooting
strategy it's not that clever because
you can't force the root system through
the office here through the parking lots
and song it's not possible so trees here
I have to have a b b c and a d plan to
take this and these guys have the
potential to be growing here we grown
well looking good delivering all this
ecosystem services they wanted in there
even if the condition is really really
challenging and the same thing when you
look at where they grow in natural and
that nature you can find them grow into
really challenging growing situation
this is ASA grunted and talked them from
a menu so in sign a tional park and if
you have to grow here you have to have
strategies more than just the root
system we rely on that if you have to
have you have to step up and take the
other one and this is from the step
forests of Eastern Europe ASA to Tori
come together with workers professions
because if you should grow here on the
steps of Eastern Europe you have to have
a tolerance to take weeks of droughts
really severe droughts and every time I
have our knee 9 audience I have to show
this picture because everybody who takes
Nina's classes she they know that also
totora can be named as [ __ ] on a stick
because thena doesn't like this tree so
that's why I just showing her how
good-looking tree it is this is from
lune Sweden on a courtyard with a
parking deck below have you seen enough
near yeah I would give her her feel
secondly
but also in the same starter you can
show that it shows that also within the
same species there is such a significant
difference between different genotypes
and this is interesting when it comes to
selection that within species you can
find both sensitive but also really
really tolerant general type or Janet or
eco type within the species this is our
red maple three different kind of
genotypes but also it's really
attractive in my new job when I have to
travel around the world who collects be
sure that this mythology makes it
possible to screen in an early stage the
potential of the species so if we are
hunting for drought tolerance tree
species or species for our or genotype
for a future climate we can use this
technology or the methodology we
developed in order to screen in early so
we don't have to wait three generation
of gardeners before we know it's
tolerant or is weak we can do a really
early screening so this is the work we
did last year so this year we went all
in to screen as many species that we
could in order to see especially among
the untraditional so this is the work
from this year and I will go through
them all
know how long but this is what's
happening when you get carried away in
your research you feel like an alcoholic
now one more glass this is like one more
species just one more day and this is
the result here so this is about 140
species of genotype we're testing this
year in order to see but then you can
see the significance difference between
species and genotype when it comes to
our pollens and the main work is not
only to to create this data set but also
testing untraditional or rare tree
species because we have to we can't just
go to conference and say that everybody
are idiots the nursery industry or the
landscape architecture industry we have
to give them some kind of guidance or
confidence in order to shift from a
traditional plant materials to testing
new plants and new species a zone and by
a this research is possible to actually
show them that for example a cumbia or
meters I think it's Chinese rubber tree
that's English name I'll look it up
sorry Hardy no ok
yeah I was wrong there anyway rubber
tree and you can see you can show them
that they're the most common tree for
example in Sweden they steal a coup
d'etat and you can show that this is
fully hard in Sweden but much much more
tolerant for dry conditions you should
be better in urban streets environments
compared to Tina Cordova which when it
comes to more into a dry condition they
have all these things going on how to do
a zone but it the same thing it's
important to identify the trees that
belongs up there because in Sweden in a
way the landscape architect really
really like my NOLA Cobras these are new
trendy trees they wanted everywhere and
they also start to force them into
Street environments but the result they
look like crap because they just have
wilting leaf in July no flowering died
off in a tree council so it's really
important also that show that many Ola
Kobus is and will be an exclusive park
tree or garden tree should never be
forced and through this research is
possible to have that kind of
communication that they don't have that
they don't have they can't take em any
punches they just they take one and then
down it's equally important to identify
the tough ones but also the weak ones in
the communication when it comes to
diversification of urban environments
it's on and through this data said I
just narrow it down a little bit to go
through some plants are some groups that
this is the Oaks we're down 22 different
genotypes of Oaks we're testing so you
can see it's a huge differences between
them also within the season bear in mind
that this axel is changing a little bit
in number so it's but also this work
this is from virtuous this is made not
here in ear canal this is made in a nest
garden which is the Botanic Garden in
Liverpool UK by Andrew Islands because
the man directed there is just wrote an
a monograph on birches they wanted us to
come there next year we have been
invited to Q garden in London to do a
screening of their trees they have
they want to know the future potential
of the tree stock to have at at the
Botanic Garden a song so the words start
to have spread there's that so hopefully
our next year we can present some really
interesting data when it comes to rad
trees from Botanic Gardens but also we
try some shrub species me Nina you can
also see this is ground covering shrubs
we just started with and play a little
bit bin but then you can see also there
there is a big difference between
species and and and cultivars but also
when it comes to use potential where the
potential is so this is what was my goal
when we started this because I will try
to explain this pretty boring I know but
I try to try to explain it
Nina meta valadares presented a paper
2006 by ranking drought tolerance for
800 wood species shrubs and trees by
reviewing where and how they grow in the
wild but this is once again just
consumptions they are between 3 & 4 so
it should be a little bit drought
tolerance but what we can show we put
our data based on their ranking and you
can see there is a relationship really
close relationship with our data with
them but what we can do we connect to
show not only like between three or four
should be there we can actually show a
number this is the how it is but also
interesting that some of our most
drought tolerant species for example
syringa reticulata
what's the name of that
there you go japanese trailer which
drought-tolerant but when you based
things on review or review literature
you can read about the species where it
grows in Southeast Siberia when it grows
in cool and moist sites but when you go
to to the mountain in China
it grows together with I'll and there's
a collet area one of the most drought
tolerant species are very very rocky and
dry sites but they've that book they
didn't read so that's why they put them
in as a not that drought tolerant so
that's there when you're reviewing
ecological literature together with the
research we doing so the as I said we
are in a start and we start to develop
this database hopefully next year we can
add another hundred to this list and so
on and working on and we have a lot of
side projects which is interesting where
you can see that if if you stress the
tree they can step it up and actually
increase the turgor loss pointer zone so
also important to see the window how
much they can take not only when a
growing in plant a park environment also
when you stress them and see how much
they can step up some species doesn't
have that capacity some species have a
very wide capacity so bear in mind this
is just the starting it but I think it's
really interesting and the most of all
it's really interesting or very useful
in order to communicate with three users
a plant user and plant designers how
much time you have that
okay then I would like to show another
perspective that we work with as well
because when it comes to plant selection
many things that trees right tree for
right sight but I would like to add
another aspect of that right tree for
right side and functions because when it
comes to urban tree or urban for today
everybody's talking about tree a
increase the urban tree canopy and so on
if we increase with 10% we will gain
this and if we ain't egg add another 10%
we will gain this that's not possible I
don't buy that I'm sorry because it's
different between trees and trees
because when it comes to landscape
architect and I'm one of the most hated
teachers in my university because I'm
the guy that shows up in a presentation
and just ask them why why this green
blob there what is it what should it do
there I don't know it's a street we
plant trees along the street and then I
fail them they have to come back they
have to every dots to have to have an
idea why and which tree should be there
because when it comes to buying a car we
don't go in and say I just want to buy a
car we don't do that because when we buy
a car we have a lot of ideas what we
want for the car what kind of car I
should I look in the car and so on we
kind of stare you and we kind of all
this bling bling but if you don't do
that if you just go in there and said I
want a car you can end up with this one
but then it's good that's a lottery but
the same time you can end up with this
one both it's a car but the capacity
between them it's different but this is
what we're doing when it comes to tree
selection for ecosystem services or
trees are good for pollution reducing
pollution or mitigating their urban heat
island so that's why we plant tree
without thinking of where to place them
and which species to use and that's very
very frustrating because it's much more
because this tree is not a tree
sometimes goes well
this isn't too good example these are
from Stockholm this is for Manchester UK
where the tree selection have been
really good probably it's just luck
but sometimes the using species that
doing a good job they're taking the wind
or shading the situation where it's
needed but sometimes it's true sometimes
you can actually can plant tree and make
more problems rather than actually
benefits for the tree and I would like
to show this is research I'm just part
of so Johanna brace you have its the
main person behind this research I'm the
plant geek I'm in the end just adding
some trees and song but I would like to
just show this this is a program a
climate modelling program where it's
possible to to see the effect of urban
green infrastructure and how I can
adjust the microclimate in a building
area it's like minecraft from grown-ups
you're building up a hypocrite here a
neighborhood in a 3d way this is a
houses then you add numbers of the
houses if you concrete house it's a
wooded house how tall they are
what kind of roof it is if you have
climbing plants and on the and also
which kind of glasses and so on but also
it's not only taking the the build up
environment but also the outdoor
environment
what kind of surfaces is it concrete
gravel grass is a shrub plantation is a
tree how tall the trees or which kind of
levels and so on and then you build this
up
it's called MV met and then you can
download it for free on internet and
then you add local climate data and then
you press the bottom and take a weekend
or 10 days or so but then you come back
and this have been harvesting for a long
time but the problem in the beginning
was that the plant data is not available
so the work we have done for three or
four or five years yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yes so we have been collecting this leaf
area index data for I think it's about
75 or 80 tree species and then we add
these values in this is what we can have
and then you can ask different kind of
question it's also for pollution but
also for wind speed for microclimate and
so on but then you can get a good
pictures it's not only you here and you
would say they have stupid politics like
Donald Trump and so on also in Sweden we
have pretty slow minded people that are
politicians but I take it but this is a
model where it's possible to to show or
to communicate the effect of green
infrastructure within building areas I
will show you when it comes to wind
speed this is the housing area with no
trees whatsoever this is the ocean
here's a lot of wind comes in so you can
see there's a really window specialist
pasar when you when you force the win in
and here you have more or less storm
every day it's really good when you do
they started to ask dog people the
people with dogs need to go out every
day even if it's snowstorm or raining so
they know you can ask them where's the
worst spot I then can actually give the
exact same what this modeling program do
but this is the effect if you add do to
the master plan weather fancy Landscape
Architect company in Stockholm did I
don't think they even we're here to look
at their website so they did more a
traditional way of placing the green
infrastructure trees here group of
plantation here and so on so you can see
that they reduce the wind something but
we died a deal on after that is to
placed just to change some of the
species to other species but also place
them in other player in other sites so
to say in order to gain most effect and
this is one proposal and this is the one
so by using this program but also adding
you can show that species selection not
only placing the species but also which
kind of species we using matters
I think it's cool and this is on the
summer but when it comes to winter you
have the brown sharing necks because we
have long winters in Sweden we need to
care about how the trees are acting in
the winters because in us in winter we
don't want them in any tree not close to
buildings because the Sun that hits the
buildings in in wintertime warms up as
much as we can reduce 30% of the heating
cost that's a lot of money we can use by
just using the Sun energy just hitting
their their facades in the winter time
so by placing trees too close in the
winter town with too dense canopy can
cool down and actually increase the
heating costs in a wintertime but then
we have a negative ecosystem services
actually that's bad so by placing trees
just increasing tree canopy without the
action to think about where and how to
place them we can actually cause problem
so this is what we want we want trees
that have a dense canopy summer times
with a lot of leaf high leaf area index
that cool down facades and building or
even if we have a square where we have
Tory handle markets or so on under
square in the summit that we want to
have shade but in the winter we want to
have a lot of Sun so what we look at is
trees that are dense in the summer but
sparse in the in the winter and let a
lot of sunlight through the tree canopy
so we did a research of evaluating
different tree species when it comes to
branch error index and this is gingko
biloba which is more like a joke when it
comes to a shading winter time because
it doesn't have anything more or less
but then we have this this is a core
Pinus Pantelis foster year after which
is a hornbeam upright care which is very
very dense so this can shade a lot but
at the same time the gingko can't reduce
any winds in a winter time because winds
is another shilling factor
so you don't want to maybe have trees
close to the buildings but a little bit
farther away to reduce winds
so ginkgo doesn't do anything while the
hornbeam do a great job for that and
then we have something in between
this is Ailanthus so we did an
evaluation about 55 or 60 species or
genotypes of trees about 30 35 years old
planted the same time planting his same
site and so on
so without ever evaluating so you can
see that when it comes to brown sherry
index that's the density of tree crowns
in the winter you have gingko this is
from stop command new gingko plantation
but one of the most dense is the upright
core pinus or the hornbeam so what we
did we are playing around with this and
we met again and then we place this is a
courtyard this is a building's the wind
comes mainly the main wind comes from
the west here and then we placed a tree
roll it looked like it's a hedge but
it's not because in the program when if
their canopy touches out each other then
it's it looks like a hedge but it's not
this just a traditional tree rope but
what we did is using the data or then
the values we collected from this the
data the Fielder brown sherry index data
and added into the program to see how
much they can reduce the wind which is a
very important ecosystem service when it
comes to Sweden anyway because we don't
we don't have that warm summers but we
have cold winters so reducing the wind
and a cold temperature wintertime it's
more important in order to to reduce
energy costs but also a really good
outdoor environment so we go through
this is gingko biloba this is normal
maple emeral Queen only long honey long
local story they did sir turkey oak
collars Kelowna fossa got hornbeam and
last upright type of of the Western
point but then you can see
so we have to care which trees we're
placing where because there is different
capacity within between species and even
between genotype within the same species
so we can't just say that if we increase
the tree canopy with 10 or 50 percent we
will gain that and this and so on we
have to be more precise we have to force
yourself in the planning of the green
infrastructure to talk about detail to
talk about plant selection but also the
spacing where to put them as on and this
is really clear clear research that
really show and this is this paper is
out it's published early this year so if
you want some copy of this paper please
let me know I will send it to you so to
summarize this presentation is that I
would like to launch the statement that
the cool people the most important
people the new superheroes in the future
will be the plant geeks because the
plant geeks are the people that knows
all these stupid facts about plants but
these stupid facts all these details are
important in order to to build or
construct recite a cilium to urban
environments so that's it thank you very
much for listening
or stream ejected and for summer yet
you're concentrating on the summer data
and more or less ignoring the day no I
judge maybe it might roll here but in
respect we care about the spring black
that is equal because it's interesting
that the weak ones so to say they have
more or less the same values in the
spring as in a solvent they don't change
that much they go out we stately but
interesting that the most drought
tolerance especially in in the summer
some of them are we will week in the
spring persona 4 the golden range rate
sensitive College Area automata
it's one of the week is in the spring
but in the summer it's may be number one
number two we know data that's so fun
it's really really strong and that's
also important when we transplant
deterrence re-establish the tree they're
very in the beginnings we have to focus
even if it's from Poland where it's
established it could be really Fred
right in an established if a specially
the screenplays that we have to be
really careful
with this adjustment from the
spring-summer if you have any adjustment
by them by the treaty because you've got
a series of small stresses during that
period we adapt to the drier condition
exactly
that's also the next step we actually
have some spin-off studies going on
going on beside this doing the try to
part of this big data that we have trees
that grows for example in the plantation
will have unlimited the same species or
even ascended up downtown the more
restrictive law we have been actually
does include penetrating robots we know
exactly how much space to have but then
you can see that the trees in the
plantation of course because if I have
unlimited wide invest that much because
everything's building at the downtown
they invest very very much much much
higher but the interesting in this data
that the court area the rain free and
the same high levels
as downtown the day just invest in very
high or very low turbulence point even
if there are standing in with unlimited
routing space they just programmed to be
greatest on from the beginning they
don't have any other thoughts but for
some of the greatest food adventure
which is the other species in same study
had this huge adjustments between
prompting and impatient with unlimited
space compared to resolve the library
downtown was very limited participation
they have it may be off or double its
turbulence point it can take it more
because they have not just go to sign so
what we see that there is among some
species some species just a bird for the
game what we can see that it's a lot of
things we have to continue looked at but
there was interesting is to to develop a
knowledge about the window how much you
can take or that just that's the next
step in its research to try to
understand which species had a very
narrowly no for example a few them
because ordered basis because if it goes
out we stay weak and doesn't have any
but then you have some other species
like where this little area they have a
plain white window or just that's the
next base to try to create these weak
them to see how why they are all matter
what they are but we are working on
they're along those same lines if you
look at our moisture release curve for a
soil a standalone soil the volumetric
water content that it water potential of
minus four mega Pascal's for example is
vanishingly small not a whole lot of
water left there might be interesting to
look at the duration of grout in
reference to something like potential
evapotranspiration to see so to speak to
use a different metaphor how long the
plant was going to have to hold its
breath that if you're investing a lot of
energy in making neutral osmotic oh for
automotive adjustment and you're going
to get another six hours worth of
ability to extract water that might be a
less prudent kind of adjustment
investment
yeah beginning of this so thank you for
going almond and I will come back here I
want to thank you for this time I really
enjoyed it I was really inspiring this
has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu